people are nuts man
they're all crazy I'm sure y'all got a
story to tell in life there's two kinds
of people those on Team Joe exotic my
name is Joe exotic and this is sergeant
and those on Team Carol Baskin yo you
cool cats and kittens it's Carolyn Big
Cat Rescue
for rapper cardi B she falls in the
first category and get this she may even
spring into action to help her boy Joe
out of prison I got these prison
appraised I'm still beautiful car D is
just one of the many millions of people
totally fascinated by Netflix's
documentary Tiger king which is centered
around the life of Joe exotic the former
owner of an exotic animal park in
Oklahoma he's currently serving a
22-year prison sentence after he was
found guilty for killing five Tigers
plus seventeen wildlife violations and a
murder-for-hire plot against his
longtime nemesis Carol basket who owns
Big Cat Rescue they have a harder than
the soul out of mind I've learned from
them but Carol Baskin ain't saying I
can't have a tiger if he ever had an
anime in his life it was Carol basket
back to cardi she was tweeting up a
storm about the doc over the weekend
first she asked her followers for their
thoughts but she eventually showed her
loyalty to Joe tweeting Thursday Carol
you think you slick and they did Joe so
dirty over and over again this is my way
of living
and nobody's gonna tell me any otherwise
but the real kicker came on Friday when
cardi tweeted this about to start a
GoFundMe account for Joe he shall be
free and get this when one fan
criticized cardi for still talking about
the dock she clapped back I stand him
leave me alone
cardi is far from the only celeb who is
totally hooked on tiger king in fact not
only our celebs watching it they're also
pitching themselves to star in the
eventual big screen adaptation Edward
Norton Dax Shepard Bryce Dallas Howard
and Jessica Chastain have all thrown
their hats in the tiger ring but you've
got to check this out
yup that's da cantle in 2001 at the MTV
VMAs handling the tiger during Britney
Spears's performance seems like the cast
of tiger King has always been destined
for big things
[Music]